it does yeah I'm like a damn attic I
really am for fast food and it was funny
as my mom she was heavy and she she grew
up the military family that only allowed
her to drink water or milk for dinner or
whatever and you know whole wheat bread
and they could never have candy unless
it was Easter for halloween and when her
her brothers and sisters grew up they're
all fat they all you know baby it was
you know the most like the whole
Catholic school girl thing we're so
sheltered they get out and start [ __ ]
everybody yeah yeah I know it's a
stereotype but it's kind of like that
you know it was sheltered from all the
sweets and they got out and I'd her she
told me one time she said you know our
mom dad would never let us really have
the food be wanting so I called myself
when I grew up and by I kids you guys
could have whatever you want that's kind
of [ __ ] me up bad but it was done out
of love so I mean but she gave you the
ability to choose though you know like
when people aren't given a choice to but
people aren't given a choice growing up
when they finally get their freedom
that's all but that's like how it was
for me and a lot of things is like you
know so the fact that she gave you a
short because she passed away too right
yeah yeah 2005 what does she pass away
from she had cancer but she also had
kidney belly yeah she didn't most people
think that she killed me if you say
kidney failure people think that she was
diabetic she wasn't hormonal natural
health schooling I found out that a lot
of times you get if things go wrong in
your body through subluxation xin your
spine you ever go to a chiropractor I
Easton okay so you know what i'm talking
about those movements of the spine that
can press on the the nerves that run to
say for example if i were to be in a car
accident and I was hitting it back I you
know in the middle of my back I'd my
dorsal vertebrae that could be
compressed on the nerves that run to my
heart
did your body makes a whole new you
every 90 days or so every 90 days
because the nerve flow is cut off I get
a weaker and weaker heart sometimes
people I had a heart attack the only to
know why because his heart got weak over
the years you had an injury he never
knew about well with her she was in a
car accident guess what was injured her
lower back oh and a friend to her
kittens and she never because I started
getting the natural health and she never
believed in it and I finally got her to
go to the chiropractor because i told
her i thought i was gonna cut her off I
thought I didn't want to hear nothing
about none of her problems I said if you
don't care I don't care so she finally
went and once she started to get worked
on by him she literally started
urinating again she could all right but
just a little cuz you know when your
kidney failure you can't pee at all you
have to go on kidney dialysis but it was
kind of too late you know because she
had already had cancer that she had had
one mastectomy another mastectomy and
then it spread to her brain or spine mr.
just it was so [ __ ] up and then I
remember they told me that they had to
take her off of kidney dialysis because
the cancer was interfering with it
working properly and you know to this
day I don't know if that was true or not
but you know I had to slowly I had to
watch her day by day lose consciousness
it was like she just went to sleep you
know over like maybe five days after
they took her off time ever the last
time I spoke to her you know I told her
I would be back to see her the next day
and you know she was sleeping like
screaming and then from then long she
never spoke que nos so but yeah I mean
that's that's that was part of my
journey man you know yeah I went oh my
my dad passed away a two to three years
ago he he had it was like 5th elder
Powell was her mom 56 that's that's how
old my dad was now Wow 56 and he had
heart disease and then he had kidney
failure and he was on dialysis for as is
weird because like the
last couple years my relationship when
my dad was really [ __ ] up you know I
out of respect for other people involved
i'm not going to divulge too many
details but that there was abusive
upbringing and i was one of those things
where what happened was I was going to
therapy and for some reason I couldn't
remember the first 20 years of my life I
just couldn't for some reason and then I
started reading this book called no
acting please which is all about
learning how to get in touch with your
feelings and then I was going to therapy
and then suddenly all hit me like a
tidal wave and then I started going
through suicidal faces I became one of
those people who started like cutting
his arms and try cutting his wrists and
stuff sigh I've never revealed that ever
know we all now we all know no so I went
through I went through some pretty dark
stages with that and before my dad died
I had actually cut him out of my life
six months prior but before that he I
remember he wasn't willing to go on
dialysis and then it's my I was my ex
girlfriend's dad was a doctor and she
took a look at his reports and said that
he's going to die sing and for some
reason I was like even though my
relationship with my dad wasn't good I
convinced him to go into out I like
start falling and stuff I'm like you got
to go on dialysis so you got to have
another year in his life but those last
six months of not like to this day like
I started realizing maybe on father's
day is when I started realizing it um I
never truly dealt with what I was going
through with losing my dad so that's of
recent it's like I'm sorry to experience
a lot of the grieving feelings again
because the the funny thing about grief
you know that it is the five stages
riders like denial anger bargaining
depression but the last one is the one
everyone forgets about which is
acceptance you know like once you go
through the [ __ ] you're gonna end up
okay he now right but I never actually
I I don't feel like I properly grieved
over stuff like I was I didn't even cry
my dad's funeral but on father's day I
was just like falling my [ __ ] Isaac
okay that's like my brother my brother
did that he didn't cry at all of my
mom's i thought i was thinking like if
you punkin wrong with you you know I was
going through my own thing I was busy
crying but you know he told me a few
years later he said he was just in shock
and just couldn't believe it yeah you
know I didn't do you know it's funny to
like you had a chance to talk to him and
you got him to go on dialysis I had a
moment where um it's it's not exactly
similar but it's similar as in like I
got a chance to talk to her really
before she died because she she had a
seizure one night well and I i was now
my mom was in and out of the hospital so
much I i became to become jaded you know
and it was just like it was the norm for
her to be in the hospital so there were
a couple of days I didn't come to see
her she always wanted to see me every
day well there's one day I didn't go see
her cuz i met this chick i was talking
her on the phone all night hahaha See
Mom tomorrow she'll be fine I'll see her
you know she had a seizure that night I
coma whoa and they told me that get over
there because she could die tonight and
when I got there it was it was the
scariest thing for me to see her laying
there just eyes wide open and she's just
going through these twitching mo geez
movement and that was it it was like she
I wasn't there she could hear me of
nothing like that and they wanted me to
pull the plug wow she she was in that
coma um for about a week and a half
maybe two weeks that's terrifying and it
was crazy man because she would like she
would just lay there that she would go
into these tix it was just a scariest
thing man well I refuse to pull the plug
like they were pissing me off I'd like
to doctors talking to me like if you
think
only if life and office so that should
almost like look I know my mom and she
wouldn't want me to pull the plug right
you know they're like she's not gonna
live through the week just so you know
you know she came out of the coma and
she lived two more months Wow I'm saying
24 months before she went I was able to
talk to her and I would a man let me
tell you I would have felt so bad I
don't even know if I would be able to
deal with it if she had died with mean
I've seen yeah Lawrence so you were able
to you know you talk to you even though
you were mad your dad you're able to
talk to him and get him on dialysis and
that's what kind of reminded me of it I
was like man you know what if he hadn't
have talked to his dad or a bad guy just
made me think about this if it yeah I
mean it's like it's one of those things
where it's like I helped out my dad in
that area i knew that i had talked to
him for the last six months I was like
at least I was able to help give him
that push to have an extra year to live
because most people will go on dialysis
die like I've never heard like they died
within a year on average so yeah yeah
I've heard average for I know people who
used to work in dialysis units so these
she was told well she told me that uh
the mobile longest people lived seven
but she ended up living like 13 14 years
and now no way yeah no way that always
bothered me that I wasn't able to help
to me because they told me she had a
really strong heart lungs like really
strong essential body parts but it was
just like that injury did that back
injury it just went to off we found it
too late was your mom like one of those
like fighters like survivor and stuff
they would always say that about it they
were because her whole thing was uh
taking care of me and my brother I don't
know anything she did like I him in my
anger stage I went to a huge bout of him
I mean I was really mad at urbana
because especially if i have read
different books on health it was just
like why did you forsake your own health
to take care of us you got to take care
of yourself so you can be there for us
but for her it was always us first no
matter what so you know that that really
gone too bothered me but then I Octane
you acceptance and realized that look
she did the best she could do what she
meant she thought she was doing the best
yeah that's what we have peaceful yeah
my ex go I mean my mom I've always
considered my mom one of the strongest
woman I ever knew cuz she had to deal
with a lot of like domestically violent
behavior and she stuck through it and if
there's anyone I should have ended up a
little suicidal it should have if it
could have been her out of any of us but
the same thing like with your mom like
my mom's not the best at communicating
like she doesn't know how to express her
heart too much oh yeah but she's also uh
she's but she's also constantly working
at any time I've been broke or can't
like she's up she doesn't hesitate like
to help me or give me more she's one of
those people who shows more by her
actions than her actual communication so
it's one of those things where you're
like growing up you're like I need that
love mom and now I don't have that in me
but when you get older you begin to
realize and accept things you know and i
think i think it's learning how people
don't do these emotional processes when
they're so important you know like
you're talking about how you're now your
mom and yeah it's like you got to sort
of go through that that blame feeling
and then also understand what's really
underneath there and stuff like you know
like a lot of people just go with what
they're currently feeling but don't try
to examine what are the roots of where
it comes from and I think true healing
comes in yeah I think a lot of it I just
didn't want to face yeah I'm never asked
a guy that slept a lot which is part of
the depression phase yeah I have been
slept left but um you said your mom mom
y'all had money problems growing up now
you're rich youtuber I do want to retire
I do want to retire I mean she's been
busting her ass for years and I got a
kid sister I mean I feel sorry for my my
younger sister I just I got blood
donated today I mean I didn't donate
blood I had blood drawn today because I
signed up her life insurance and I'm
santander that's it did you do it yeah
yeah I don't trust Murat again I owe the
[ __ ] you're doing out and a movie thick
with that guy thing now that [ __ ]
paranoids being a lot it's kind of hard
to deal with like I've seen like she has
this movie coming out that one the
biggest film festival award the audience
award at the biggest la la film festival
that's like d film festival to be in
maybe and won the award and she's in
like every [ __ ] scene but there's a
couple of sex scene moments and it's a
little hard to sit through